we ran a simulation about three years
ago in Davos where we had a number of
global investment professionals talk
about how allocating money to different
sectors in particular may be a good
demonstration of where the economy was
going over that particular year and it
was an interactive exercise where
different teams were thinking about the
allocation process and thinking about
what the implications might be for M&A
and other activity as part of that
particular exercise before we wrapped up
we gave people an extra option that we
didn't announced before which was
instead of putting their investments
into particular industries they could
instead put it in a safe Bank in a
Treasury so to speak or what we called
under the mattress it turned out after
we finished that exercise that thirty
percent or thirty five percent of the
overall allocation went to the mattress
and it was a very very interesting
example before we actually had everybody
put up their results there was a more
lighthearted element or more
lighthearted aspect to the room where
people thought what industry will it be
how will things compare however once we
actually put up the results and people
realized that by far the dominant
investment was putting money under the
mattress it dawned on the collective
group that actually there were very
significant implications for that
because if money collectively in the
system was not going to be put to work
we ran the risk of a real slowdown in
the global economy as business as
government and as others looked at a
potential slow down with everybody
sitting on the sidelines and therefore
having a spiral that would reinforce
part of the problem that in turn led us
to looking at what was taking place the
following year and unfortunately it's
part of what actually occurred if you
looked at what happened in the following
year the global economy slowed down
considerably in part because of an
incredible investor hesitation to put
money to work in different ways and I
thought it was interesting story where
sometimes the discussions that doubles
that even seem light-hearted at first
can be a dick ative of a broader dynamic
can be indicative of the fact that
there's very serious issues of foot and
with the benefit of hindsight I wish
there was more that we could have
to work with not only that group but
some other players in the global economy
to talk about how that hesitation to be
active could put money on the sidelines
potentially exacerbate a difficult
conversation